vous vous êtes 8 yens oui si vous fait
que mes seins caméra excusez moi la
diminution a démarré déjà on est au bout
du rouleau
donc où se ressaisit vite ou bien ça va
pas se passer comme ça vous parle alors
est-ce que vous pouvez refaire le bail
oui est ce que vous connaissez caméras
caméras mais il a jamais vu en fait les
dindons 5% d'audience à l'époque sur les
enfants dans le peu de côté la veille un
film qui sort là aujourd'hui
deuxième meilleur démarrage d'un film
pour un manga et on a filmé la réaction
des geeks lors de l'avant-première
regardez c'est pas piquée des hannetons
c'est les auteurs qui sont extraits de
lancement virus ya pas mal hein y'a pas
des russes de dépression qui va ça
j'annule l'image non
quoi qu'ils aient pour l'annulation du
match iran vous avez 30 secondes pour
voter quai pour l'annulation de l'image
attention mettez nous une musique
d'attentes s'il vous plaît ma vérité
éclate vous avez demandé l'annulation
d'image cherche le téléspectateur vous
avez demandé une annulation d'image
quittez pas nous recherchons votre
correspondant elle annonça les folles
[Rires]
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre sur ces huit
mois tout tu voir le résultat
que se passe-t-il allez-y vous avez
demandé l'annulation d'image ne quittez
pas de rechercher votre correspondant à
trois ans ferme non les gens sont
indécis
non et bien non eh bien non tout un
travail réduits en poussière à meillon
regarde du théâtre oui on puisse aller
merci à vous avez font plus débat